mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
das kunsthaus zürich eröffnet seinen
neubau mit spektakulären sammlungen von
sammlern die unterschiedlicher nicht
sein könnten hier der millionenschwere
waffenhändler emil gebühr
exklusiv für nazis und wird achsenmächte
waffen produziert und geliefert und ist
integraler bestandteil sie vom nazi
umstiegs komplex dort werner merzbacher
der vor den nazis floh und dessen eltern
im kz umgebracht worden dass ich wenig
wunder dass jetzt mit mir reden denn
wenn nicht die luft klar hätte dort
regelt weder werden
ein kulturplatz gegen das vergessen
[Musik]
wir kommen auf dem kulturplatz ja
endlich ist es soweit der
erweiterungsbau des kunsthauses zürich
öffnet seine goldenen tore das werk von
architekt david chipperfield spaltet die
zürcherinnen und zürcher mich überzeugt
dass in seiner puristischen eleganz in
jedem fall ist das kunsthaus zürich
jetzt das größte museum der schweiz ein
grund zum feiern keine frage doch zur
eröffnung werden auch misstöne laut
neuerdings wird mit der sammlung des
ehemaligen waffenhändler stühle ein
bedeutender kunstschatz hier im neubau
zu sehen sein doch genau diese sammlung
sie wirft einen dunklen schatten auf die
helle kalkstein fassade wir gehen dieser
sache nach
nach sechs jahren bauzeit ist es soweit
der erweiterungsbau des kunsthauses
zürich öffnet seine tore
hier hängen nun einige der bedeutendsten
malerei der welt
der knabe mit der roten weste von paul
cezanne seine bhs von 1879 oder das
mohnblumen feld von claude monet
der gesamtwert dieser meisterwerke wird
auf bis zu drei milliarden franken
geschätzt sie sollen die limmatstadt
nach paris zur wichtigsten adresse für
impressionistische kunst machen doch die
werke stammen aus der umstrittenen
bührle sammlung umstritten deshalb weil
der sammler emil bührle die werke auch
wegen seiner waffengeschäfte mit den
nazis im zweiten weltkrieg kaufen konnte
wie soll man also umgehen mit einer so
bedeutenden moralisch aber auch sehr
belasteten sammlung
lukas gloor ist seit 20 jahren direktor
der bühne stiftung deren kunstwerke nun
im kunsthaus zu sehen sind im vorfeld
zur eröffnung des erweiterungsbaus hatte
die geschichte der mühle sammlung
niedergeschrieben die dank mumien da es
andere jetzt die chance egal in dem
szenario wie geschichte verfasst also
der versorger sie nicht loslösen wird
der problematischen sitte ich erwähnen
wird das ganze aber komisch wodurch die
brille damit die bilder kräfte da war
man nicht verstecken aber
sammlung als solches ist doch bis wo
es entstanden ist seriöser wirkt diesen
umgang mit dem schweren erbe soll ein
kleiner dokumentations- raum im
erweiterungsbau leisten hier sind die
unterschiedlichen stationen von gilles
geschichte zusammengefasst seine waffen
dienst mit den nazis aber auch die
jüdische sammler im zweiten weltkrieg
ihre kunstwerke verkaufen mussten und
wie diese dann bei bälle landeten diese
kontroverse mussten wir aushalten von
anfang an war klar für dieses haus das
die sammlung mit hier einziehen muss
weil sie in die öffentlichkeit gehört
weil sie in gewisser weise auch der
öffentlichkeit gehört und dabei war auch
klar dass wir über diese kontroverse und
schwierige geschichte ihrer entstehung
würden reden müssen diskutieren müssen
und dass man sie hier auch
nachvollziehen kann der
dokumentationsreihe stützt sich auf ein
forschungsprojekt der universität zürich
über die geschichte des waffenhändlers
und kunstsammlers bühne
das forschungsprojekt hatten die stadt
und der kanton zürich im vorfeld zur
eröffnung in auftrag gegeben das ist
zusammen mit dass man einfach nur um
diese schöne bilder ausstellen sondern
blüht wenn es über den steg von der
bildergeschichten bild
wo die bilder entstanden sind und viel
musik macht dann wo sie besitzen und
besitzer gewechselt und sind
interessiert von kontext verstehen ich
glaube das ist eine innere innere
moderne präsentation
muss das heute zu erkennen
jahrzehntelang waren die umstrittenen
kunstwerke in wörlitz wähler beim
zürichsee gelagert oder finanziell
defizitären bedingungen nun ist die
vermählung der bühne kunst mit dem
kunsthaus also dank historischer
aufarbeitung möglich geworden doch
reicht das
kritiker sagen dass der spektakuläre
erweiterungsbau diese schwierige
entstehungsgeschichte der sammlung in
den schatten stellt und dass die stadt
zürich damit vor allem standort
marketing betreibt
der historiker erich keller arbeitete
ursprünglich mit am forschungsprojekt
zur bühne doch er fühlte sich von den
auftraggebern der stadt dem kunsthaus
untermühle stiftung bevormundet und
stieg aus nun hat er ein buch
geschrieben das kontaminierte museum ich
glaube der name politisch wirkt dermaßen
kontaminiert verstrahlt belastet das
wird mir drehte sie war sogar denn
zurzeit bezeichnen denn mit wie das
vampir
anders ist mit der kunstsammlung
versucht man jetzt unterscheiden
interessante vorgang mit der branche
zählt dabei ihre geschichte die
geschichte quasi auch hinter sich und
redet jetzt auch sehr gern wieder von
einer meister bei auch immer der musik
zeigt die schöne kunst ist wie eine mit
dem anderen
emil georg bührle waffen fabrikant mit
zehn kunstsammler
in der zwischenkriegszeit kommt der
gebürtige deutsche in die schweiz und
übernimmt die werkzeugmaschinenfabrik
oerlikon er führt die rüstungsindustrie
ein und wird zum wichtigsten
waffenproduzenten des landes er verkauft
waffen in die ganze welt im zweiten
weltkrieg dann aber fast ausschließlich
an nazi deutschland
dabei erhält der viel rückenwind von der
schweizer regierung
[Musik]
vorgestellten und vor allem durch
optimale bedingungen wohnen die
schweizerische bundesstaat
stadt und kanton zürich zur verfügung
gestellten der hätte vielfacher ebene
profitierte vor dass man sich geschäfte
unterstützte richtig angestachelt wurde
vom bundesrat war von asus liefert
bilder erhält den schweizer passen und
wird dank der waffengeschäfte zum
reichsten schweizer jener zeit
er hat so viel macht dass man ihn
zuweilen den achter bundesrat nicht
er ist nicht nur rüstungsindustrie eller
sondern auch mit 10 und kunstliebhaber
mit
den gewinnen aus den waffenverkäufen
baut bühne eine große kunstsammlung auf
über 600 werke erwirbt er bis zu seinem
tod 1956
es ist ein eigenartiger geldkreislauf
komm raus doch stark von
finanzmittel wo er werbe worte sind
derbe mietgeschäft womit natürlich
ethisch sehr fragwürdig beurteilen und
die werte wiederum in der stier in
meiner kunst markt produkte von deiner
verfolger von deiner kulturgüter
fertigen moderat stattgefunden hat das
ist ziemlich einmalige gelegenheit mir
ist kein anderer sender bekannt welt wie
du in der not und wie es profitiert hat
es beiden ebenen
untertreibung
wenn eine sammlung also auf moralisch so
problematische weise zustande gekommen
ist soll man sie überhaupt zeigen oder
will man sich überhaupt damit schnitten
was von dieser aura verschmähte übrig
geblieben ist ist eben nicht die firma
sondern ist eine kunstsammlung die muss
nun nicht stellvertretend seien für
alles aber man kann sie nicht wegsperren
und sagen gibt es nicht interessiert uns
nicht weg aus der stadt es ist teil
unserer geschichte hier in der stadt und
auch ein geteilter geschichte der
schweiz und das kunsthaus übernimmt
diese verantwortung gern dass wir sie
jetzt zeigen viele der bilder gehörten
jüdischen sammlern bevor sie bei kühle
landeten die provenienzen sind alle auf
der webseite der bühne stiftung
aufgelistet
raubkunst existiere heute keine mehr in
der sammlung so die stiftung so
genanntes flucht gut jedoch schon also
werke die jüdische sammler auf der
flucht vor den nazis verkauften
diese kategorie unterliegt in der
schweiz aber keiner gesetzlichen
restitution pflicht
wir haben das nicht unter schluss
vorläufigkeit gemacht sondern
permanent auf unserer website das
dokumentiert man zeigt was man kunden
jeder wobei uns vorgestellt hat
unser archiv betreffend hätte auskunft
nico für den historiker erich keller
reicht dieses vorgehen aber nicht das
problem hatte für die prominenz
forschung ist dass sie zu keinem
zeitpunkt unabhängig sich die studie
geführt wurde von der eigentümer selber
oder bürgerstiftung ihr resultat sind
hier umfassend kommuniziert worden sind
darum hier wieder seitlich wird durch
verschiedene forscher die sogenannte
peer review verfahren zum beispiel mit
kollegen teilt überprüft kritisiert
verbessert worden
oktober in transparenten vor schädlichen
black ops ein aspekt in der zeit wird in
der ganzen aktuellen aufarbeitung gar
nicht erwähnt die fragwürdigen
arbeitsbedingungen in den zivilen
unternehmen von emil erpel
dieser war auch in der textilindustrie
tätig ihm gehörte etwa eine spinnerei
und eine weberei in dietfurt im
toggenburg hier schickten fürsorge ämter
in den fünfziger jahren heimkinder zur
zwangsarbeit wie ein artikel im
beobachter vor kurzem aufgedeckt hat
immer frei war eine dieser
zwangsarbeiterinnen 60 jahre nach dieser
zeit kehrt sie an den ort zurück da hast
du einfach nur müsse funktionieren der
fabrik du hast mir zu schaffen und es
ist sehr strenges regime sie oder du
hast auch nicht groß können geräten oder
computer
oder auf die pause machen und so das
einfach nicht dazu machen wie die
maschine die hat mir sehr langen vorlauf
verlaufen und produzieren das ist
wichtig stück sie
als junge frau wusste immer freilich
dass emil georg bührle der besitzer der
spinnerei war eine entschuldigung der
bühne familie haben sie und hunderte
andere frauen nie bekommen dies glaubt
nach 6 uhr
wären entschuldigung fällig
denn das
alte erlebt hat -
das ist stunde jugend
dieser teil von görlitz machenschaften
bleibt dem kunsthaus vorerst unsichtbar
es stellt sich die frage wie sehr man
hier in zukunft bereit sein wird solche
und andere details ausführlich
vergangenheit mit in die dokumentation
aufzunehmen hier ist definitiv platz für
mehr dann müsste auch weniger diskutiert
werden ob es für die stadt zürich vor
allem um standortmarketing geht steigen
aber stunde für europa die stadt dass
man sich den herausforderungen nicht
stellt sondern dass man ein so genanntes
standortmarketing setzt also statt
theorie will sich positionieren als
wirtschafts schwergewichte schulische
zukunft
wie der europäische topliga würde man
sehr mitspieler für das ist ein neubau
für das ist ganz ganz wesentlich für die
museen sind öffentliche orte der
erinnerungskultur
sie dürfen nicht hinter geschichtliche
erkenntnisse zurückfallen
sonst werden wir in 20 jahren ganz
anders auf diese werkschau
ja mir stand da jetzt auf dem heimplatz
das ist die trasse vom kunsthaus und der
platz ist an verbunden mit der
geschichte von emil bührle und natürlich
auch vom kunstschuss und bei mir ist der
jakob tanner emeritierte
geschichtsprofessor von der uni zürich
was sind verbindungen
musiker komponist schweiz
das wirkungsfeld wunder hat schon
unzählige schriftsteller und kabarettist
franz hohler oft falle das daheim eine
fast immer könnte und der rettung zeit
der nur kleine kontrakt zudem gülle bau
und der belebung das ist eher mickrig
und stößt ihn am ziert vom wasser
fabrikant und rund 200 mg und dass ich
sie zu sehr spannen die geschichte
zweite wahl foto der bühne zum sechsten
mal boten ist zeigte sich bereits neues
kunst münster einer 15 aber das klingt
für die zwischenzeit dass ich blutgeld
vom ersten bis zum letzten rennen musste
brutto investiert über der waffe handle
19 54 stellen der durchbruch gelungen
und der listen zu 640 überraschend
gestorben rund 650 welt wurde aus
gedanke 4 und zuerst sind die gemälde
von peter zeichnungen
[Musik]
jakob tanner der mlb hat ja nicht nur
probiert der grundstufe fluss sondern
autobahnen im schauspielhaus und das
macht der heimplatz so interessant wie
ist das damals durfte der 44
diese show daraus
antifaschistische theater gespielt wurde
von einigen assemble das sind mit
schauspielerinnen und schauspieler aus
deutschland frohsinn deutsche schweiz
zuflucht gefunden und hochkarätigsten
der hand der bürger hätte am anfang von
zweiter weltkrieg versucht ein völliger
neubau des theaters finanziert das
projekt hätten aber nicht auf probe
bemerkenswert ist dass das
antifaschistische theater und auch der
direktor oskar wälterlin das geld
eigentlich gerne hatten um die wette
beziehe ich einfach wenig bedanken aber
dann ist emily juli mit weniger erfolg
im fluss wieder im kunsthaus
wahrscheinlich mit dem
sozialdemokratisch regierte auf offene
ohren gestoßen aber aus verschiedenen
gründen die ihr projekt nicht abhoben
und dann hätte sie habe erneut im
grundstücks einer sinne wirtschaft zu
ergründen was ist dein ziel zu vermeiden
lässt ihn einfach um macht gegangen und
fluss es geht ganz profanen grund das
ist spür optimiert kultur kann man von
der kriegskunst angeben ob sie denn
hätten auch politische unterstützung
durch software schwarze liste von
alliierten dass es schwierig werde
verdienen und dennis nicht zuletzt um
darauf vor gesellschaftlicher anhängig
das mäzenatentum sowie in der luft sehen
erreger oft vor zehn jahren dann aber
letztlich doch nicht ganz gelungen nicht
nur zurück normales kunstschuss von huth
vom 20 21 mit einer sammlung bührle kann
man sagen dir wirklich von der sammlung
nicht groß genug geschätzt werden juli
wird dort wie zum zweiter großer zentrum
vom impressionismus nach paris und doch
ist das schwer belastet wir selber mit
einem erbe ungehört
es sind großartige gemälde fußgänger aus
phoenix revolution mit den
impressionisten
jahrhundert als sammlung bührle als
einheit ist sie aber hoch problematisch
ein hauptpunkt auch dass oskar wie vor
der sammlung bührle saal darunter
nordische unterbruch zeiten unabhängige
instanz sollte das macht und das ist
nicht der punkt
jetzt werden wir über die autokratie
umgang mit dem erbe die nächste frage
wir werden in zukunft mit dem erbe
umgang vor allem mit welcher optik wird
man darauf was ist da ihre sicht auf
zukunft also wird man sagen ja das ist
da ein exil wo mittwoch verkündet hat
und das ist grund dominiert und das wird
so bleiben oder wird man das vergessen
wenn schließlich liegt mit der
vergangenheit vom zweite werk in der
lage
mir vergessen dass aber der bühne eine
waffenfabrik und ceo von netzwerk
profitierten
bundesbudget schwere tier mit einer
klärung auf der die waffe überhaupt
finanziert dass der film geschichte vor
der ganzen schweiz im zweiten weltkrieg
involviert ist danke für das gespräch
herr kopp der
neben der bühne sammlung zieht eine
weitere großartige sammlung in den
neubau des kunsthauses es ist die
sammlung von werner merzbacher als bulle
1939 beginnt waffen für den zweiten
weltkrieg zu produzieren steigt wärme
merzbacher mit 300 anderen jüdischen
kindern in konstanz in den zug nach
zürich es ist seine rettung seine eltern
werden im kz ermordet
der heute 93 jährige werner merzbacher
spricht mit uns über sein leben seine
vergangenheit und seine leidenschaft für
die kunst
[Musik]
es ist kaum noch eine wand frei beim
kunstsammler werner merzbacher in den
letzten sechs jahrzehnten hatte eine
hochkarätige kunstsammlung
zusammengetragen im juli dieses jahres
musste er abschied nehmen von seinen
gemälden wenn auch etwas wehmütig an die
ganz schön fühlt wo ja
behandelt
aber ich glaube ich glaubte immer nur
den schluss und richtige entschluss
gefasst hätten dass das hätte schon ist
grundstufe
die sammlung merzbacher konnten den
neubau des kunsthauses
neben bührle
[Musik]
bei die biographien sind geprägt vom
zweiten weltkrieg
auch wenn sie gegensätzlicher nicht sein
könnten
haben dem land bin ich dem land dankbar
dass es mich steht
wie sie das schließt wunder dass jetzt
mit mir redet denn wenn das
wenn das damals neu ist seine idee nicht
die rüthener hätte dort entweder wäre
schon
merzbacher hat es weit gebracht und das
obschon seine biografie alles andere als
vielversprechend anfing
geboren in der nähe von stuttgart musste
er als kind 1939 deutschland verlassen
nachdem es den juden verboten wurde in
die schule zu gehen schaffen es seine
eltern gerade noch rechtzeitig ihn mit
einem kindertransport in die schweiz zu
retten
ich bin sportlicher typ sie und
begeisterte fußballer und der kurze zeit
von ich nehme auch eine schule bin ich
die ganzen dürfen fussball.de und ich
habe mir das dass sich der fußball immer
am kann wenn ich meine eltern
vom zug
abschied nach
und
natürlich nicht dafür viel mehr würde
ich haye
seine eltern sterben 1943 im
konzentrationslager majdanek im selben
jahr exportierte
kriegsmaterial für über 100 millionen
franken an die nazis
die letztlich aber eine letzte nachricht
seiner eltern fand merzbacher erst
jahrzehnte später nach dem tod seines
bruders rolf mein lieber rolf
nun muss ich dir leid durch doch
schreiben dass wir vor der abreise sind
nämlich nicht schwer
mein kind wir hoffen dass bald alles
besser wird
in inniger liebe deine mutter
der ältere bruder kam schon 1937 nach
kreuzlingen konnte aber psychisch mit
dem tragischen schicksal seiner eltern
nicht umgehen und er sagt nicht ich her
nach münsterlingen zu behalten und die
hand nimmt dann
elektroschocks kur unterzogen
damals ohne
narkose und er hat dann spürte immer
verteilt neben verbrennt
merzbacher hatte mehr glück
überlebte den krieg bei einer
gemeindeschwester in zürich
danach wanderte er in die usa aus
heiratete er eine schweizerin und kehrte
erst 1964 zeit im pelz geschäft ihres
großvaters begegnete er erstmals an der
kunst sein
die bilder vom großvater dass die bar
impressionisten wie ich sowieso dass der
mond schon froh wenn ich je erfolgreich
wird sie dass ich selber das führt
machen
und erfolgreich wurde er im pelz handel
wie auch in der finanzwelt
kaum hatte er genug geld begann fast
schon obsessiv optionen zu durchforsten
um seine bilder zu finden
wie dieses bild von modell iannis
geliebten anbietern mit einer tragischen
geschichte und viel zeit mit ihrem
fehler auf ihre buch wo sieht das zweite
kind erwartet das aber nie geboren denn
nachdem er dann stoppe ich hatte er hat
ja später war zum fenster gestürzt und
hier sehen die dem bild die tore vor dem
was da auf die wirkung
[Musik]
es sind solche geschichten die seine
sammlung ausmachen die jetzt im
kunsthaus zu sehen ist
[Musik]
meisterwerke der moderne aus der
persönlichen sicht eines sammlers und
das alles gleich neben der sammlung
bührle
ich werde immer wieder vor der wie hast
du jetzt das umgebungslicht wie die
gülle und der kurdisch eigentlich dass
es geschieht das überwiegt alle
politische
gedanken wo
ja die leute die mich aus skeptisch
machen aber entscheiden die schlimmen
das ist der typische
märz barras maxime ist vergeben aber
nicht vergessen
seine sammlung steht auch für die die
nicht so viel glück hatten wie er
[Musik]
nach dem bild run gilt seine
leidenschaft nun den blumen
[Musik]
kennen sie 100 zwingli also wenn dann
kennen sie sie virtuell denn es ist eine
figur auf instagram dahinter versteckt
sich ein kollektiv das die
untervertretung von künstlerinnen in den
museen und in den öffentlichen räumen
anprangert und damit kommt natürlich
auch immer wieder mal das kunsthaus
zürich ins visier von holder mein
kollege nino gadient von sf kultur auf
instagram hat versucht 100 zwinge zu
kontaktieren
naja was für das symbolische zwingen
über diese figur wird vom männlicher
künstler bionische wissner-gross die
weiblichkeit
diskutiert mit der öffnung von kunst des
neubaus tour aber die fiktive frau dort
und zwingli digitale aktivistin stört
sich doch recht ein männlicher über
präsenz in die kunst
geboren ist oder am tag vom frauenstreik
2010 ihre vorbilder sind guerilla girls
us-amerikanische aktive stimme wo sieht
40 jahren für mehr weibliche kunst in
der musik kämpfen immer anonym genau wie
tun
[Musik]
was ich denn das wo du fort ich holte
kurzer rundgang in der sammlung von
kunst zürich mit dem ärger
was sagt kuratorin
kunst und
das gesellschaftliche
20 der aktien ist
weg die ganze bestand haben
nur was für künstler gibt es überhaupt
in der kunstsammler und das haben wir
ganz sorgfältig machen und hat dort die
wirklich historische positionen gefunden
wo man vorher nie ertragen bereit für
code an und jetzt präsentieren sie
hat ein großes problem sei das werk wo
für frauen gemacht worden sind in eine
weitere und ehemänner zugeschrieben
worden sind russell der ändere auch die
männlichen kurz 100 zwingen befindet das
geht unser riesiges gefängnis
gesperrt sind
in dem neubau muss man mal abwarten
was nicht von männern und frauen hat es
ja auch schwierig das war unsere sendung
zum kunsthaus erweiterungsbau in zürich
und zur frage wie wir mit belastetem
erbe umgehen wollen der nächste woche da
begrüßt sie hier meine kollegin nina may
dispo und nimmt sie mit nach montreux
auf die spuren des legendären freddie
mercury und gleich hier geht's weiter
auf sf1 mit der sternstunde philosophie
und der frage die welt retten aber wie
zu gast die deetzer chefin patricia dunn
zu kommen sie gut durch die wahrheit ist
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen der kultur
swisslos